oh there's notice great that was fast
but Dan we're live five four three two
one live what is up guys
sir tango yeah sir does the guy I assume
guy that was like please kill me oh hey
guys you know they're at the live stream
hey what is up man everyone before we
get started I just want to say that this
is a international broadcast guys we
have animatic from anime uproar in
Canada we have Mack Mackel not all the
way from Canada Canada and Brent from
Canada I can totally relate to you guys
yeah so yeah so we're all from Canada
but from different parts of Canada so we
we have a very diverse outlook I think
and for this stream let's we're gonna be
discussing guys versus girls
anime tastes anime preferences all that
kind of stuff the different categories
shown in show Joe etc and a lot of other
other fun stuff so let's introduce
ourselves first I'm Anna Boch who cares
Mac Oh me yeah I'm Mac I play video
games and people watch it sometimes yeah
eight times a day in macro not twitch
channel checker what are you 25 times a
day let's listen we don't stop we don't
start it we just we just do it I see
refresh I Rev what's up dude
oh is round here he is what is up rev
you know it's Nico nice what up Nico
what up Nicola
oh by the way rolls you can go ahead and
introduce yourself oh I totally didn't
those next hi I'm rose I talked about
anime yeah that's a fun thing I do yeah
he rolls you're with us the last stream
too and we have a new guest this week
the amazing bread from Brent's fandoms
Abram hello hi I'm Brendan and I talk
about Amy stuff on my channel and it's a
fun time so if you want to come on by
you should come and say hi these guys
their channel their links are in the
description they all have awesome
content and yeah I check all your guys's
channels the regularly because I really
like your stuff and I really noticed
that rose and Bryn whenever you do our a
a nice review it's like two thousand
views in like two hours
that's one of the reasons why I think it
will be good to get to discuss kind of
why we think that Yuri oh nice and anime
like that are so popular and I would
dare say mostly among girls for that one
some guys dig it
yeah I haven't watched it only because
I'm not big into sports anime like I
gave free it's fair chance like I gave
it three episodes like to you know sink
in and try and entertain me right I just
I don't know I don't sports
I don't sports that's just me I don't
sports either but I like it like Heidi
is like the oh nice voice anime really
that I watch but then this one I'm like
it's a good time you like good stuff
yeah yeah I know some guys that are into
it but mostly girls though but in
general I like sports animes depending
on the sport I usually pick it oh the
sport over what actually happens so if I
think apparently I thought figure
skating was gonna be cool and it was
cool but I usually picks the sport over
the actual like story figure skating is
cool like to watch for the Olympics for
sure I feel like I
usually watch it like ever on other
occasions but like in the Olympics I
feel like it's really amazing and then
it's so funny because like they'll slip
up like a little bit and you don't even
notice it and then the judges would be
like oh no they're done they're done for
why that was amazing I can't even skate
by the way true story I can barely skate
you call yourself Canadian we're in I
want to say that I really like your
channel art like it's thanks it's super
awesome and cute I don't know where you
got it but like I want you to teach me
how to make that pro features like okay
how do you like yeah we have the cute
one and we can make you the cutest
little kitten ever it is adorable props
props on that for sure so yeah you're
young ice
I haven't given it a chance I admit but
I'm wondering what the appeal is because
so okay assuming that it's that this is
true I actually read that the biggest
audience for like yaoi anime / manga is
actually middle-aged heterosexual women
in Japan so I wonder what you guys think
like assuming that's true why would that
be like what where is the appeal because
I admit I don't watch any anything close
to Yami or URI really so I can't speak
but I am curious Rosie
I mean throws a pretty you could let me
think um what is the appeal of it ever
they're just cute cute boys I don't know
do I need to explain cute boys and why
they're cute do we want to go into that
want to see cute fanart check out my
Twitter because I tweet it every second
tweet I feel like there it's just like
Victor and Yuri are just beautiful
people on their own but then when you
bring them together it's just the most
beautiful thing and like it's just so
cute okay so when you say beautiful do
you mean physically or do me in like
personality definitely both like and
they just I feel like they just work
really well together like some ships
like some actually like yeah we like
couples you're like why are you guys a
thing like this doesn't seem right but
like these two are like like made for
each other out I just I really like
their relationship thing going on so and
oh gosh do we venture into the zone of
yaoi
but like the reason why it works is
because there's usually like the older
and the younger like top/bottom shall we
say that's why that's why it kind of
works like that's what a good like
relationship at least in like yeah it
terms is we won't go into that maybe but
like it just works I don't know I like
it but I don't normally watch a lot of
this stuff but I like you're nice
because it kind of surprised me that
they have this relationship was not
expecting it at all 100% not expecting
it so that was kind of fun well you
weren't expecting it because has Yuri in
the title right Mac tell us why you love
your E&I so much well we're gonna need
an hour so I haven't I haven't watched
it yet I do plan on giving it a fair
chance like not gonna knock you're just
gonna like dis it off cuz its figure
skating it I don't watch figure skating
but I noticed the like the art was
pretty cool like the look of it just the
general
it looked pretty cool but other than
that I haven't really seen it so I've I
can't really give my two cents on URI on
ice
well according to elf and silver armor
you are the Yowie King he said yo a king
and then someone replied saying
Sugoi I mean it does sound like me okay
oh hey which King which King is my
Serbia guy
my fellow Serbia guy nice what's up my
brother
[Music]
but ya know Ivan I haven't seen it
enough to to get my two cents on it
other than the art looks kind of cool
and I don't really like figure skating
so I don't know how far I'm gonna get in
it but we'll see how she goes and she
goes she goes if she doesn't she doesn't
mmm
worst case scenario I can just watch
Clannad for the fifth or fourth time or
something in yeah I think we all love
Clannad but one anime that Mac you do
like that I couldn't get through I got
you in two episodes is or on host club
so tell us about you why you love or on
host club so much and don't skip out on
the skimp out of the twincest well let's
be real like it like as everyone here
seeing Ouran High School Host Club I
gotcha
I watched it it's good stuff it is good
and that's the thing even like as a
straight dude it's it's you can still
you can still appreciate like the comedy
aspect of it and I know it's it's
probably meant for it's probably not
meant for my age group or like it's it
it's a good show I did it has is good
comedy moments it's even like even if it
is kind of made for a different
demographic like it's I still found a
lot I could still enjoy about it like
even even the English dub was good which
is rare just not the opening the opening
huh let's not go there let's not go
there but no it is it is a good show I
think it was maybe like this I want to
say it was like the fourth or fifth
anime I ever watched it's also one of
those ones that's kind of like it was
there for the beginning so it's it's
kind of one I always remember and enjoy
but you want to say that pal placed
trademark TM and REM are active in the
chat and Rev is saying that he highly
advised us for the four of us to watch
um blue dragon no I don't know what that
is it's a little older like kind of
fantasy ish it looks cool I think it's
the same development team as Digimon
I think but I've never watched it but
he's told me a few times to check it out
so I do i do plan on it whether or not
I'll finish it though that's find out
next time okay so what about the whole
category thing of like Shonen and shoujo
right because we have this shown in
which is for younger men or boys and
shoulder for younger girls and then we
have same end for older guys adults and
then I think it's Jo saying for girl
slash women well like dude does anybody
actually agree with these I know that's
the target market but does anyone
actually agree with these like
classifications because I feel like a
lot of this stuff we watch doesn't
really fit cuz I'm sure you guys have
seen like coal Geass which is like
Shonen right like the ladies yeah I like
watching all sorts of anime like some of
them you can is kind of for all
audiences but generally speaking I think
it's hard to mess up a scene in or like
a mature audience cuz it's like very
clearly for a mature audience
but even then younger viewers can still
access it so it doesn't really matter
but like generally speaking hero which
is like a shown in for like boys you
know like a boy show but yet I still
enjoy it I think it's a lot of fun but
it's more that superhero target market
of people but yet I am not obviously a
young boy but I still enjoy it yeah I
feel like it's definitely like you can
enjoy both of them like I watch both but
you could definitely see the distinct
differences in the subject matter but
like still I feel like like I still
watch both like I watch those two no
hero you know kind of thing yeah yeah so
I might be I might be the guy that's
kind of like buying into this
classifications because like I tend only
to watch really Shonen and sane and
stuff I think not just intentionally but
because I know my brother goes in he
likes honey and clover I don't know if
you guys have heard of that but that's
technically classified as a shoujo and
then I kind of gave him some heat for
that but he says it's amazing I don't
even care man it's beautiful but like he
says it's similar to climb at like for
example I love Clannad and it's funny
because when they were showing it on TV
here like they on those cable channels
they have like they classified it as a
girl power and Clannad was classified as
girl power so it's like but in fact it's
actually shown in right because it's
like the harem stuff so I feel like the
the classifications don't really fit
that well and definitely max love for or
on host club also proves that time but I
wouldn't like marry it's not anime not
of all time believe it a fan as long as
it's on my gravestone um mohawk Mohawk
Aurora says hi amen how's it going good
to see you and I think elf is calling me
out I think elf is like anime up Roy air
your scrub Oh
elf is still a little troll I see yeah
elf says he's defending you he's
defending your honor he says I can't
talk trash about you or su as I know he
will strike me down he will show
minami don't don't worry elfis here's
all that free speech even if even if it
probably gonna make me cry like I don't
fall asleep better it's no problem yeah
we built it as someone will cry that's
the point the rant is not real unless
someone's crying tonight on the because
on the topic of of like you know
demography and like who it's supposed to
be tailored to I think it also kind of
comes down to like personal preference
of the human like I I dig things blowing
up that's cool but I find most of the
stuff that I watch is like almost more
like soda shoujo stuff like a like a
like blue spring ride I really like blue
spring red it was really friggin good oh
depending like there's a lot of bad like
harem animes that I've seen that are
like this this is garbage like well like
I can't get into it
so I guess it depends like it really
depends what it's about like it I don't
know just I guess it comes kind of comes
down to personal preference and what
what your tailored to like some people
are more tailored just you know like
shown in stuff things blown up giant
robots which are cool don't get me wrong
don't get me wrong but just depends what
you're into I guess yeah okay go ahead I
was just thinking you could take the
discussion of like you know even
something like Gurren Lagann which is
not for like female audiences but yet I
super loved it but yeah I mean it's not
necessarily tailored to like if an anime
is done well it can reach any audience
it can like go past anyone flip in your
mind here like attack on Titan like
really pop you're like Code Geass all
those ones really popular ones are going
to be popular because they are just good
not necessarily because they're targeted
for like certain people I think we can
all think we can all agree that sword
art online is the actual best anime
no but seriously the old Bryn actually
Gurren Lagann is my favorite anime of
all time and I love it but it definitely
has like the kind of fanservice with
like Yoko and stuff that's geared
towards guys but like the the I also
find like Mack was saying with the whole
kind of really edgy anime like it's just
like one guy like a bunch of girls but
like those can be very much like bland
and kind of uninteresting even though
you're a guy it's like there's no plot
it's just like these unrealistic
scenario so it doesn't mean that you're
gonna enjoy those just because it's like
intended for guys because like I've I've
seen like girls problem and things like
that is just like it's still frustrating
in many ways because I I guess what I
really like about enemies if I can
relate to some of the characters like
relating to the characters is my number
one thing so when I watch like an anime
like even in Mongolia like a galleon is
great because of the philosophical
themes and things like that but shinji
is such a crybaby like I hate crybaby
characters cuz I guess I love come on
characters to inspire me not just to be
like oh well this is life and life is
hard accepted kind of thing so that's
why I obviously a lot of gorlok I love
coming up because that's my idol right I
want to be like that I don't want to be
like some it will help me life is hard
kind of thing so yeah that's like the
deeper tagging it's and like anime like
girls Bravo we're kind of like clueless
and it's like oh I'm so cool as but
girls still love me for some reason like
I can't relate to that whereas if
there's an anime that's geared towards
guys or girls and they have relatable
characters I think I would definitely
enjoy them yes well this isn't this
isn't a rant cough a few guys are all
agreeing oh you're wrong I disagree
disagree with everything you've said
yeah no no fairy tale yes fairy tales
pretty good but I haven't finished it
cuz it's not finished and I'm lazy so I
kinda it's so long yeah
I think I like gave up by like 120 or
something I give about like around the
same like a hundred hundred ten or
something I just got confused by like
that seven-year times gift I was like
there is a seven-year times yeah yeah I
go round there like I stopped like a
couple episodes after I'm pretty sure
for what fairy tale
hey Tam oh yeah I'm like episode 50 I
was actually watching in French to
practice my French but then the French
Netflix which I get totally legally like
they only have up like 50 episodes and
then I stopped there like it was
enjoyable it's fun and then that's
another one I think like is that a is
that as shown a jump like anime or is it
made by someone else
I think it's shown in John Mongkok sure
I think that in one piece oh my god
know that rule Sean and jump right cuz
even even they're like that's one that
it's a shounen jump one but it's also
liked by everybody like it's not just
not just you know like little dudes it's
like it's everybody it's big dudes it's
big girls it's cool it doesn't have to
be like all right you're a girl so you
have to watch you know orange and air
and Cannon and then you're a dude you
have to watch blow up explosions like it
that's just it you can watch whatever
you want and it's awesome and I feel
like when you like like shows like that
it's kind of like you watch it for
different reasons like I watch it cuz
I'm just hoping that all my ship's get
together but they never will but like
obviously other people watch it for
different reasons
so it kind of like depends on what
you're watching it for so you're one of
those people that cares about ships rose
because like I never got those people
like me it's always like well I'm gonna
read about this on my chest
obviously in tonight right you cannot
it's like you have to be totally on
Augie side or as Mac knows them Tomoya
and nagisa because if you walk it's dumb
but like yeah for some of those things
it's like they have to be together but
for most of the time like I don't really
watch British ships ships just really
ship it depends on how much I like the
show or like how much I like the
characters like if they're boring
characters I don't care like they could
get together they could break up I won't
really care but if it's like if it's
something where I can like you know
connect with the characters then ships
start to matter that's like okay you
need to you need to back off this but
these people need to you know it depends
on depends on the character depends by
the way Mohawk Arora said that he agrees
with me that character should be
inspirational and he's actually a really
cool youtuber he and speaking of
fairytale he makes like fairy tale
cracks like funny fairy tale across it's
for mature audience as I will say that
much but they're actually quite funny I
enjoy them he's not a pro viewer
discretion is advised
has anyone seen by the way on Eureka
Seven or America 7 yeah yeah I really
like it from what I remember yeah I
watched you like a long time ago but I
really enjoyed it from what I remember
like I just said yep it was good Johnny
Yong Bosch sounds like just the biggest
crybaby the entire time but it's it's
it's a good show there's a lot of cool
characters and explosions oh dude it's
one master well one master welcome he's
from Finland he's actually it's like
12:30 a.m. over there but he made it
glad to see one master the capital D
yeah that's so early like it's 5:00 okay
and it's pitch dark outside
no wrenches
yes yeah it's pitch-dark it's fish dark
outside and have you gone fishing in the
dark that's what that's I feel like
that's a really Canadian thing to do
right like you like fishing no I like
fishing in the dark
anjaneri in ice because I'm Canadian ice
fishing URI on ice season 2 URI on ice
fishing no that's real that's real
that's super real my heart this froze
one master and echad he's like yay
thanks giggles to be here and this is
like looking back like yeah I'm not good
but that is a compliment because the
book is awesome and I love his content
he's hilarious but actually yes so the
the Eureka Seven thing I actually wanted
to say that is the biggest
disappointment anime I've ever watched
so I was wondering if other people
actually liked him because I hated it
really but it was such a letdown like it
was interesting at first like I thought
it was like a really good set up an
interesting plot line and then the
protagonist is such a useless crime I
did every moment of looking at his face
the main characters were fun like they
looked like a good setup and then like
the plot dragged on and on and it was
like what is going on like I think that
would be like my biggest disappointment
anime after Tokyo ghoul and like or on
post love which I told you guys I
couldn't get through like Tokyo ghoul I
got like 7 episodes in me and goes I'm
washed together and then when they
brought that like weird sexual cannibal
guy I was just like okay resigned he's
so interesting though he's so
interesting oh no he's sexually
attracted to cannibalism yeah we get it
man we get it light good game nore
matched
I actually really enjoyed the end of
Tokyo Google like I know it's not done
and they left a lot of stuff out and
apparently like they ruined it from the
manga but the ending so I just sat in
the corner of the cache just like no I
remember
yeah right that's something I did what
you said in America that's okay please I
don't I don't care so much yeah so Tokyo
ghoul Eureka Seven definitely flops in
my opinion yeah I guess I'm just I'm
just uh sophisticated taste guys I guess
I'm like why do people like Tokyo ghoul
and good night one master yes to go to
bed it's very early there but we really
appreciate you coming out I appreciated
the most actually just keep that in mind
I disagree yeah I respectfully disagree
red rat that's that's like your Canadian
rant right it's like well you make a
good point sir but I will have to
disagree so um what else do you think in
terms of the differences between guy and
girl anime because um Mac you actually
mentioned Kanaan right I did I think
yeah
June - come on but I think that's
technically a shounen actually I guess
it begins it depends I mean it's kind of
it's got the harem aspect to it like one
dude super generic looking everyone
loves them for some reason but I mean I
don't know I feel like the whole five of
its a little more I'd say a little more
tailored towards the opposite sex I
don't know that's just me I still really
liked it don't get me wrong but I don't
know I guess that's I guess that's up
for up for debate I don't know why you
say that it's unrealistic for you to be
loved by many many women like to me
that's just normal life isn't I forgot
my life was a hair of my bed but such an
easy thing to forget right right
I guess you talk about reverse harems
like I mean a lot of reverse harems are
geared towards women because like they
place themselves in like the main
character and couple seasons ago there
was a show called princess stride it's
based off a note to me game so it's
based off a choose-your-own-adventure
you know choose your boy adventure game
and so the main character was like super
bland and super dumb but all these boys
are like super good-looking and like
trying to seduce her those I think are
definitely targeted towards either yeah
women or men who like men kind of thing
like to people a certain audience that's
gonna like that
yeah but wasn't that or on hold because
that sounds to me like you're describing
or on host club like to be fair I
haven't really I didn't watch enough to
it to know about the personalities and
stuff well like to me that was that it's
like this girl that looks kind of boyish
that's pretty average and then
everyone's like fawning over her it's
like oh you're so cute by the way
look is my hot brother and we're kind of
weird yeah I mean I think it's I think
the difference with or on it's a little
more it's meant to be a little more on
the funny side whereas something like
like prince-sama for instance it's I
don't think it's meant to be funny
although I I did let I didn't watch the
whole show I watched like two episodes
cuz I gave it a fair chance mm-hmm
there's an episode and I think it's near
the end or something where they like end
up like joining hands and flying into
space or something like that and it just
ends I laughed my ass off at that it was
hilarious but I feel like the whole show
was geared more towards like like what
Brynn said so I mean I didn't really
want you yeah if you guys want to watch
really ridiculous reverse hair I'm you
should watch it Diabolik lovers
interesting show my two roommates were
me and Mac do reactions to reverse
harems and you guys do reactions to the
worst like harem harems are there good
harems yeah go say what are good normal
harems out there do you have any
suggestions for us well other than like
Clannad angel beads sort of I mean
there's a lot there's a lot of dudes and
angel deeds no are there any good like
good actually good harems I know next
time on travels I don't know probably be
in like the edgy category if there are
any harems they would all be in that
type of category so yeah cuz even like
show Jackie no soma
that one's but 10 chili one depending on
how you look at it there's a lot of
girls with
big boobs run around so classify as one
that sounds appealing now quality
content
I suggest wait away
is anyone else only singing back I feel
like Mac is the only one on screening I
hope like because I'm only seeing you
Mac and I'm also only seeing you on the
actual YouTube page so I think
everyone's just looking at you right now
everyone I'm looking at everyone else
rim Jim Richardson says animal fur what
up Jim well yeah we only see you Mac on
the youtubes like you might not have the
YouTube page open but it's only nice oh
I was gonna say I see Rose on the
YouTube but no I I said I just need to
shut up for five minutes or turn my game
down me no but it's not bad
oh yeah that's alright did you click him
I'm unclicking him like I think I did
not click him initially there say That's
not me
what is going on are everybody welcome
to the makkal not show I'm so sorry we
could just all try our impersonations
and see who wins because it'll just be
your face but our voices right right you
can / you can overdub me yeah oh man
sounds like a great time new topic of
our stream hangout should have just yeah
they did they're supposed to it was
doing that until recently I don't know
why now it's it's just just knock on
there I don't know I didn't click
anything initially so I'm seeing you
talk right now
like don't open up for me when I unless
I'm seeing something totally different
than what everyone else is seeing I was
heroes now I see you now is he yeah
let's play the who does everybody single
file yeah we are seeing some some
changes now
okay on the actual speakers there's of
the way but yeah what is uh I was
probably just talking a lot no it's not
I think it's I don't know anyway
elfin silver armor I love you too so
much so much that we are elephants or
armors have been saying notice me senpai
image yeah the whole time
I noticed you I'm Sam by the save
yourself noticed I would love to see an
elephant silver armor Michael not anime
that would be a good [ __ ] I think any
anime about me is probably a bad idea or
I love you see so some people love me
too Mac it's not just all about you I
love you more than I like me I wanna see
you on the thing it's not like I make
these streams just for you or anything I
quit and we're not friends anymore so
congratulations
I wonder still on are you still on the
screen alright her only I was on the
screen now I'm hoping it's gonna go to
normal like we'll see if okay now I'm
switching okay thank you thank you God
yeah I think there was some kind of lag
going on because like I wasn't seeing
like on my screen right now I'm not
seeing awake movement but on Facebook on
YouTube it's actually seems to be moving
right so I don't know let's go with its
back to Mac now like I guess I can
switch you guys manually I think I
switch you may know for some reason it's
not the texting on its own so so let me
know who wants to talk in a la
everyone else so yeah everyone can just
voice over clearly though yeah too
heavily promote Mac into that moustache
okay there's Bryn we're okay hey just
remember just remember now when you're
on a certain when you're on you're on
like don't like do weird stuff while
someone else is talking okay I'll try
I'll hold off you know oh my time my
time is now so time to shine I'll try
I'll try to unclick we'll see if
anything happens I don't know if it will
Roger Smith took 2000-2004 says enemy
offer oh hey Roger Smith 2004 what's up
buddy 2004 is a good year I did a lot of
cool things in 2004 like watch TV yes so
we're back basically it's either Mac
it's either we're at Mac or we I have to
manually switch it for some reason so it
seems to be a conspiracy where this
whole thing is just a promote market has
mustache someone said that in the chat
cyanide blizzard said that in the Chad
you just like this this whole thing is
just a scam to promote Mac and his
moustache OC rollers we're going to you
oh no no I'm not an entertaining person
I don't know how to YouTube how does one
YouTube what is the youtubes you can
talk about a recent while I'm airing
anime right now that guys really love
mMmmm no I don't know what it is [ __ ]
GU guess lifters know why me yeah well
yes but there's another one that I'm
thinking of is it that one yeah
okay Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
yep I literally watched a minute of it
and said nope nope
no thanks don't really want to watch
this so did you guys watch it I have no
clue what you're talking about oh man
look at the trailer oh my gosh what's it
called
hey Joe kei Jo you'll probably notice it
by the big but in thumbnails big Woody's
in the thumbnail yeah yeah Jo yeah yes
yeah I've heard of it and the reason I
actually heard of it is who cooks like
he did like a comedic sort of preview of
the fall anime that are coming out and
he was just like ragging on that Keijo
thing and I was just like because it's
supposed to be a sports anime abuts I've
gotta like what wrestling like I don't
know what's going on but I haven't seen
it yet I don't I don't know if I want to
see it but I just watched the trailer um
I'm not sure you want to either yeah
exactly excited for it cuz I thought it
was maybe another slumming anime that I
wouldn't watch but then it like it
totally turns a different direction and
then I was like well no yeah that's a
lot like me and Tokyo ghoul this is
gonna be an action anime a little bit
dark and it's like no it's just sexual
cannibalism that's not all there is hope
Tokyo ghoul sexual cannibalism it's all
errands yeah but yeah no I'm gonna take
a hard pass on interesting words Paul
plays TM is Lindy he's like notice me
like yeah I know I noticed you la Vega I
defeated you at brawlhalla
and it was
a blast it was epic we actually did our
first gaming stream like my first gaming
stream with Mac and his twitch channel
back on Saturday we did brawlhalla
because it's like I don't know do you
guys know what bra Hall is it's like
it's like Smash Bros you know what Smash
Bros Super Mario splash brothers it's
like a fighting like a Nintendo stop
fighting game well this is basically
kind of a Viking slash like warrior
version of that so it's like God but
it's acted on and it's free on Steam so
anyone can play and you can play up to
eight players just like fighting each
other at the same time online so we did
that it was really fun it was my first
time streaming a game thanks to Mac and
his awesome twitch channel and then we
got a bunch of people from the chat and
so we played it like eight people
free-for-all everyone fighting and the
last night standing kind of thing and it
was fun and I want a few times and so I
was I was pretty cocky I'm still you
will remember me Latika you will
remember me Paul places studio bones is
us and they made FM a I agree to both of
those things
we have full metal baby by the way I'm
still like manually switching between us
so if anyone's like what is going on
it's Google Hangouts it's all about it's
all about the makkal nuts you know yeah
yeah pretty much
it's like it's like maybe they're his
sponsor it's like Makela brought you by
Google Hangouts you can see like the
stream it's like this tiny little box
and the big fan or it's like a cross you
just can't see anything else that's what
I planned that's what I planned
surprised this is much so this is my
channel now it's over
but yeah good at brawlhalla
I agree bottle and brawlhalla again soon
you're good you're good man in asthmatic
says you're your gentleman scholar
gentlemen Dennis Keller gentlemen and a
scholar
well yeah Mac so basically this Google
hangout stuff is not not fixing so you
if I'm just gonna manually check when I
would win someone's stop talking and
we'll see what happens like I could just
manually like put it on everyone just
like let's see what happens it's yeah I
don't have it opened oh yeah well then
you miss that under fun any other
unconventional animes that you thought
that you weren't gonna like or maybe
we're gonna like and then you ended up
watching it and you're right what is
this kind of like cage oh wait I thought
I was gonna like either one like so do
you thought you were gonna like but
didn't or one that you I thought you
weren't but actually did and Rose were
going to you oh I'll be like reporting
to studio it's like so we're going to
Rose in Saskatoon Rose I mean almost
where I live but not quite I mean what I
mean I guess I'll talking about hi to
you because you know I don't like it at
all but actually that's I don't like
sports anyway I avoided them completely
I was like no don't like sports anime at
all it's so unrealistic I don't get it
and then I watched IQ and then now I'm
obsessed though that's like my main
number one like something I didn't think
I would like because I didn't like
sweating right but then I watched it and
now it's one of my favorites so done
talking next person that's cool actually
because I haven't seen high QA but I've
heard really good things and I actually
like volleyball a lot of people here in
North America don't really care for love
but I like European sports like I don't
American football I don't watch how to
understand baseball even hockey sorry
guys but like I watch like actual
football Oh
like Holly well I like European handball
like all that kind of stuff so yeah I
think I should check out IQ hi we're
going to you Brennan on Delaware where
oh yeah totally that's it yeah let me
think shows that I like didn't think I
was gonna like oh I watched I'm super
embarrassed about this but I watched the
full like three seasons of Bhutan oh
prince so I don't even know because by
the end I kid you not
there's about 13 boys and they all one
by one confess their love but it takes
like 10 minutes so it's like the whole
episode they're just confessing their
love but then three episode like three
seasons in like oh okay well I'm I'm in
this pretty deep I guess so I somehow I
watch it and now I'm at this point where
I have to continue it because I've spent
so much time watching it but yeah you
know you're like oh well look at me I'm
in this like that's that's kind of where
I was like with Eureka Seven like I
watched it
Kolby I think it's better and also Black
Butler because I watched Dogma because I
liked steampunk slow cuz like Full Metal
Alchemist is steampunk right so it's
really cool well like I watched Black
Butler and I was like okay I'll get it
like I never really got into it first
season was okay so I guess easin got
real weird like not not like Tokyo ghoul
I'm never gonna watch this again weird
but like really weird really weird but
yeah definitely
yeah he's once you get into an anime you
kind of like you're like 20 episodes in
you're like oh I have to finish it I
feel like committed so when the
confession is like who was confessing to
who they were all confessing to each
other or like to a girl like Britain
sorry I missed that I was chatting in
the comments repeat that again like 13
guy his professing like each other to
exalt no to the main character girl and
she's not anything interesting I could
tell you that but there are three groups
and now in the fourth season there are
four idol groups what spoiler alert so
each group has at least three boys one
of them has five one of them I think is
seven so there's a lot of boys all
confessing their love to one girl
so that's okay that's like harem but
like hardcore style it's like oh I like
three four people that's for amateurs 13
in one of the show if you want all the
boys there's no best boy it's all the
boys macklemore on you Michael not in
the Northwest Territories please tell us
some anime if you can think of that you
thought you were gonna like but didn't
or that you didn't think you were gonna
like with it good question
and I should have been thinking about
else is that I was disappointed
am I ever disappointed so how are all of
you did you did you yeah you already did
one a.m. in America I'll do one um what
I didn't think that I was necessarily
gonna like was grin Lagann at first
because my brother saw it first and I'll
never forgive him this because he always
reminds me remember who got to watch
Grimm on Bravo remember but I didn't
like when I just saw it kind of like
briefly it looked very like or to talk
kind of animation and things so like you
could mistake it for just pure Derek
Mecca kind of Shonen thing like action
mainstream thing but that's if you don't
approach it with kind of like an open
mind same thing would kill a kill right
like us the same guys made it both and
they kind of make it where it is over
the top like the comedies over to talk
like gesticulations are over the top
it's all like crazy like someone who
doesn't like enemy who doesn't
understand enemy or know the norms would
probably like what is this this is
cartoon it's just as great lenses Bugs
Bunny or something like oh they're
running around jumping around
unrealistically all this kind of stuff
well like I found it actually when you
give it a like a chance and actually
kind of look at it and look at the
tropes and things that's making fun oh
because it's very meta both Gurren
Lagann ain't Killick he'll kind of
parody in some ways other anime and
norms and anime and things like that so
yeah like that's the studio trigger guys
are definitely an example of an
unexpected sort of way to look at anime
like they they're very meta they're very
surprising I grew that know someone else
told me to put the camera on them so I
don't have to keep looking at it I mean
an anime that I thought I was really
gonna like and I thought I did really
like it was sword art online I started
it and first half of the first season
like holy crap this is like this is like
top 5 anime material this is amazing and
then they've left the game as soon as
they left the game I was just like this
this this there's no like there's no
fear of dying there's nothing like that
what happens when they die now they
respawn there's nothing there and the
fact that Austin went from like super
badass oMG please just earth me so much
so I can't stand looking at her anymore
and I don't know the only thing I liked
about it was the last dark of Sao - or
they kind of dropped some reality bombs
on you and you're like oh ok that's sad
and then so that was good but other than
that I really I can't do sword art I
just get disappointed when I think about
it now so that's that's what I kind of
thought I was gonna really really like
and then really really didn't so what
did you guys think I'm support our own
line cuz that's obviously a very
controversial anime so I mean I still
enjoy it obviously like I had problems
with a lot of the things and they're
like awesome I was like I loved here at
the beginning and then like you said
totally just weird but downhill but I
mean I feel like it gets more hate
than it deserves like I feel like it's
just like a fun thing to do now it's
just hate on sword are not behind like
so many of you to become yeah it's like
horse Dan way ever shorter it online I'm
like I still enjoy it I still enjoyed it
for what it was true there are flies but
like when I watched it I liked it so
that's just me
good point I'll get to my point - but
bran you wanna weigh in on this
yeah I feel the same way about things
like it's still a good show it's just
near the end that it was not so good and
that it started to fade real fast but I
did like was it technically is the third
season the new one where they're in the
gun Gale place I actually liked that
because I was like okay new world like a
little bit darker a little bit like you
know Mecca II but then it went back like
it just switched right back to the
fantasy stuff like oh I just got into
this world so I wish they would have
done a little bit more that and they
just quit stop going back to those gangs
because you think they would have
learned their lesson yeah so those are
good points and I like I like that rose
you said that you still like it's tough
because I actually really like the setup
to like I really enjoyed the idea of
being trapped in a game and that
actually your life depends on it it's
it's crazy it's like it's a huge leap
right leg but for not to happen in real
life but it's still it's cool I like it
I like the concept the virtual reality
on this the character development is
what is the issue right like so you like
you guys mentioned with astana her
changing and then and then the we like I
like the first arc then the weird incest
thing like why like what wasn't that
what is like half sister or like cousin
okay they're cousins totally it's almost
like they just wanted to like explore
every like cliche in anime like at one
point so they're like okay so well first
we'll do like a fantasy thing then we'll
do like a incest weird thing then we'll
do like the girl is a an action hero and
then the girl is really girly they're
like like yeah I don't know well I also
want like the gun girl stuff I thought
that was cool
oh and and actually I didn't like that
arc at the end Mac you did I thought
they were gonna go into that whole
Nordic game like the Norse mythology
that they kind of started and then I
boarded it for some reason like and went
into the whole astronaut being the main
character all of a sudden like what was
that like I didn't like that at all like
first they were obviously kid it was the
main guy and all this other way
well astronaut her friends are gonna be
the Santa my friend from now on and then
it's like oh she meets these people and
it's like oh well now we're best friends
and we love each other now it's like
what it felt so forced to me like that
part
defend yourself Mac I mean I kind of
felt the same way at first like I was I
was glad it wasn't you know based around
god-king Carrie to the man human dude
but I think I think it was an egg it was
a nice change of pace that it kind of
focused on Austin and not being just
like damsel in distress but also also
her was it like her half-sister like
sister or something like they came from
the same dad or something but the I
don't want to spoil it for anyone who
hasn't seen it but the whole what
happens to the sister if that's what she
is it just it just dropped in so much
like reality it's not like oh hey this
person's dying from super rare disease
like no she's got something likes it's
super serious you're like oh damn like
then like it makes you think like people
make like make jokes about that kind of
thing like all the time like in South
Park and stuff and just just everywhere
in mainstream media and then it just
brings in that reality bomb like this
this isn't something to joke about like
this is seriously no no and then and
then you feel all bad because cuz you
know this new character that just came
in who I really liked as a character
like she was really like upbeat and
happy and stuff just like it eaten away
just like it sucks even thinking about
it kind of sucks but I really enjoyed it
cuz it kind of brought in that brought
in reality and it still exists reminds
you that it's it's a real thing and it
sucks when it Evans but that's just me
that's just me
that's very deep Mac and I appreciate
you opening up to us it's it means a lot
and by the way one master recommends log
horizon and overlord as two of his
favorite animes but to get back on topic
yeah I think that you make a good point
Mac I like like the emotional
rollercoaster they take you on there my
problem is I kind of felt forced to be
like maybe I should say rushed because
like yeah it felt like they were
starting up the whole come to Nordic
mythology game because remember they
were going and in the bottle who fought
like Thor or something or like a guy who
was like yeah like yeah yeah yeah they
were one for Thor's hammer or something
and then all the sudden from that like
they set up there's before different
worlds and like the demon world is going
as well
I also go get cool this is interesting
and then they just went to that whole
thing I don't know if they ran out of
budget or something but then they went
through our whole thing and then in a
few episodes they had to do that whole
emotional rollercoaster ride and that
kind of felt to me like forced or rushed
I guess but I see your point
I said defend yourself and you did a
good job I was I was gonna randomly put
the camera on Brenda are you good
actually we were having a slight chat in
the chats someone was talking about free
and I was like oh that's a good one to
talk about cuz that one is like almost
100 percent for girls like that is the
girl a girl fanservice anime oh there is
free eternal summer you know the free
franchise because they are literally
half naked all the time swimming one of
them is always in a speedo and like they
have the most unrealistic bodies ever
but it's like hey girl look I'm good so
that's like the most fan service fee and
like the boy without going into like
Yahweh and like all that kind of stuff
that's probably your closest that you
can get yeah there I mean it's it's
definitely like live like I didn't
finish it I got like three episodes and
I was like no not doing this but there's
from what I've heard like I have a
friend for instance who he watched it
and he really enjoyed it just cuz of
like the
like the actual story so I think there's
if you go and do it with an open mind I
think you can you can enjoy it no matter
who you are but I don't like sports
anime and I also don't like like naked
dudes yeah well I feel like yeah
definitely like girl fencers why not
wait on them that was well a lot plenty
of guy fans but yet tamil disha like I
haven't even seen free I don't even know
what it is so I told you that I'm very
like I guess shown insane and like I'm
not necessarily purpose but that's just
seems to be what I end up watching but
you know actually I don't know if it was
a hell for or something and I love water
pools surbhi yep the champion and
European champion just come on come on
we have the best swimming bodies and
serve you I'm just gonna say it right
now but but wouldn't it be good to make
an anime that's like a great water all
anime but if we could be not just like
looking at a boys team working a girl's
team but bulks so like have some nice
swim swimming fanservice for both
genders like oh there's a girls team and
then there's a boys team but they're
kind of rivals but some of them are also
in love and it's like but we have to win
the match and it's even better a
fanservice anime for both but it's Marco
Polo Championships everything is up for
grabs
and there's actually a show called
Martin Apple and Netflix is anyone seen
it no I've seen a little bit of it my
roommates we're watching it and it looks
it looks cool looks cool
yeah I definitely enjoyed history Amy I
really like Marco Polo in the show it's
fun and it's kind of like Game of
Thrones
and although the those Mongols are total
copy of the Dothraki if you notice that
but I definitely enjoyed the show and
there's a lot of fanservice mostly for
guys it's dramatic there's Paul
telephone dings memory so I recommend
that watching Marco Polo Marco Polo a
best anime 2016 in what it is a good it
is a excellent anime all right anyone
have any other interesting topics so I
can take the camera off myself
Mac I'm going to you one master says he
wants to watch yuri on fire oh no not
good yuri shoujo anime out there
so I guess Yuri on fire would be a Yuri
an actual Yuri animal not a Miss like
terribly misleading anime like
firefighters maybe but like female
female firefighters fighters I'm gonna
take a hard pass on that one but you
could probably sell that to a developer
somewhere then make that a thing okay
I'm gonna make that sale real picture
class of female firefighters who are
very very good-looking and they have to
prove themselves in the harsh world of
man and they're all very good-looking
right it's like there's fire there's
good-looking people there's drama
tune in for Yuri on fire got the chills
just and and they're all they're all
Russian yeah alright so I think I think
we we got far in the stream I think we
established clearly which gender is the
superior at the tool and all that fun
stuff so no I didn't establish that the
you know they have we have the marketing
kind of the sort of well this is for
girls and for boys but it seems that
most people don't really are
real anime fans I guess a real fans are
not really stuck in those categories
because we we know there's some really
good show joining them out there to guys
enjoy and clearly you ladies have seen a
lot of Shonen anime say in an anime that
you enjoyed so yeah it's like we
shouldn't be hung up on the
classifications too much obviously some
are really like Fitness one side the
other side and somewhat hard to get
through was we established with like or
on for me or Yuri for me or a lot of
stuff for me yeah Brinn any last
thoughts concluding words and also let
us know about your channel and what kind
of content you do before we sign off
sure thing first of all girls win
ladies first right we win always we're
gonna we were just gonna be the winner
since anyways so girls anime Yuri a nice
free all those great lovely girl quote
quote animes is great but I am Brynn I
my channels Bryn's fandoms the link is
down below but you can go and find me
and I talk a lot about anime stuff on my
channel and just have a good time a lot
of anime content so if you like those
kind of things then that's where you can
find me on my channel yeah Brynn thank
you I agree about your channel I don't
agree about the other stuff I disagree
but the Canadian way do the French
French Canadian okay before I continue
to embarrass myself let's go to Mac Mac
tell us who you are and what you do and
what are your concluding thoughts oh
yeah concluding pods clearing someone
how is the sketch on this time of year I
assume that's where you live
we'll go with that live in Saskatchewan
it's very cold final thoughts I mean
keep your mind open you never know when
you're gonna find something that it's
awesome just just cuz it's just because
it's made for were tailored to a
specific gender you might really really
like it or you might hate it but keep it
mind open but I make I mean I'm back I
make things I make really sarcastic
videos that I pass a lot but they're
usually about anime and dirty things so
if you like that come check it out and
be probably super unimpressed but no
yeah I'm Mac Mac is a fun guy he has
really funny content and he also helped
me do my first gaming stream on his
twitch channel also be here they gotta
check out his twitch channel as well if
you like gaming and we're gonna do some
pro Hollow soon I think again so that's
yeah that's yeah those gaming on his
twitch channel and he's very very good
cool community and lastly goal but last
but not least going to Rose who is also
in Saskatchewan welcome Saskatchewan did
you know that said that there's there's
just like Saskatchewan and Ottawa that's
all yeah
concluding thoughts I agree with friend
girls win I agree with Mac be open and
then my own personal Assad is go watch
cheerio nice yeah Rose I do actually
just uploaded should've been up by now
if I know how to YouTube Yuri ah nice
review so if you watch you're a nice go
check that out after family self promo
but no no that's fine because I bet he
has like three thousand views by
anything I'm gonna start putting I'm
gonna honestly Yuri on ice you know all
my titles it's like it's not Yuri ah yes
I was gonna buy your nice fish
new comedies get out now Yuri ah nice
Anamika nice and just have you trying to
skate is there a good anime north or
like anywhere near anime north to speak
and a hundred percent do that gonna be
hilarious that would be funny it's like
the girls will be like this is not what
I was expecting
Thanks you're just like sliding on the
ice like this man is not very graceful
and artistic in his movements I mean
there is a convention near me where
there is lots of ice you should all come
in January we actually in Canada what's
it called G anime convention I think
that's what it's called
just like the letter G yeah we'll check
that out that yeah I think we can wrap
it up now thank you everyone very much
for coming everyone was in the chat who
was chatting with us hanging out with us
everyone who's watching afterwards why
weren't you here you're late you're late
no otherwise thank you guys very much
thank you guys for being our guests
simply rose Bryn's fandoms makkal not
the Joey King Mackel no it is null
Hannon it has been decided in the chat
it's not it's not up to me Mac sure I'm
pushing it hard but I might have made
some banners and I'm now also
advertising on a TV but I mean listen to
the voice of the people I'm just I'm
just doing what the people want and the
people want Mac the yaoi King the people
obviously don't know what they want the
people I'm gonna be just the
I didn't have anything prepared I'll
take you guess so
it was a pleasure guys having you here
and everyone in the chat and we're going
to be doing the next episode of rain
cafe possibly next week on Thursday
we'll let you know and we're gonna have
another guest called all-day anime so
check out his channel he's gonna be our
guest and I think what we're gonna be
talking about is this is already
preliminary but we're gonna talk about
old versus new anime and the kind of
snobbishness that comes from certain
people to like on the old anime and why
they like call me old anime and what's
wrong with old a new anime if anything
and of course all you guys are invited
back anytime to rent cafe rose Brinn and
Mack just let us know when you can make
it I know everyone's busy so we can't
always make it we're gonna aim to do it
every Thursday at 5 and we'll keep you
guys posted and until next time see ya
space cowboys and a Mack out